du 3 au 11 juin les bénévoles de la
Croix-Rouge française seront tirelires à
la main sur le terrain pour aller à
votre rencontre à l'occasion des
Journées Nationales de l'association
Martine Delabarre vous êtes avec nous
pour parler de cet événement présidente
de la délégation Évelyne de la
Croix-Rouge alors vous nous disiez tout
à l'heure la situation a un peu
particulière traversée par l'association
c'est le cas aussi pour d'autres
associations sur le point de vue des
bénévoles donc ces journées on le
rappelle elles ont pour but de collecter
des dons elles sont l'imagine primordial
pour poursuivre vos actions vos actions
auprès des publics elles sont
primordiales enfin c'est dont sont
primordiaux parce que on a besoin
localement de d'argent pour faire nos
actions comme tout simplement et
effectivement avec les crises les
épidémies qui ont eu suivi des crises et
de l'inflation c'est compliqué pour les
personnes de se nourrir ils ont des
besoins qui ont beaucoup augmenté et
nous en fait on nous demande beaucoup
beaucoup donc il faut donner à la
Croix-Rouge puisque c'est une journée
nationale de la Croix-Rouge bien sûr
entre le 3 et le 11 novembre
dans les 11 épiceries sociales que nous
avons ainsi que le camion mobile que
nous avions Croix-Rouge sur vous que
nous avons également donc c'est vrai que
ces journées nationales c'est aussi une
journée de reconnaissance pour les 2000
bénévoles que nous sommes dans les
Yvelines et pour les 600 salariés qu'il
y a également dans les dans les Yvelines
c'est une journée de cohésion enfin une
semaine de cohésion très importante et
qui va nous permettre de faire des
actions donc alimentaires ça je vous en
ai parlé
l'action alimentaire en premier lieu
mais d'autres actions sont assurées pour
la Croix-Rouge vous savez que nous
gérons l'urgence nous devons répondre
nous sommes auxiliaires de l'État donc
nous répondons lorsque nous l'état nous
déclenche pour tout pour tout un
incendie des tout ce que vous voulez et
là nous avons des coûts quand on montre
un centre d'accueil il nous faut des
lits qu'on doit changer souvent des
lipiks qu'on monte un jour vous viendrez
apprendre comment on fait non non mais
c'est voilà on a beaucoup de matériel à
acheter quand on fait des formations au
grand public même si elles sont payantes
quand on doit renouveler le matériel de
formation au premier secours grand
public on a besoin d'argent donc en fait
on a besoin d'argent pour énormément de
choses en fait
je pense aussi aux maraudés
effectivement des personnes en face des
bénéficiaires qui qui ont besoin de
votre aide mais se procurer des denrées
alimentaires coûte plus cher aussi pour
l'association à la fois l'essence pour
les maraudes et on est nous Samu Social
donc on fait beaucoup de maraude de
partout dans les Yvelines les Yvelines
c'est un grand grand territoire donc
quand on part du Nord on essaie de
répartir pour pas le DF enfin le tout ce
qui est électricité c'est vrai que tout
ça ça a augmenté on le prend de plein
fouet donc effectivement on a vraiment
beaucoup de dépenses qui ont augmenté
donc n'hésitez pas vraiment donner même
un euro je veux dire vraiment
l'équivalent d'un repas c'est ça avec un
euro on peut déjà aider l'association
non mais effectivement il faut donner il
y a plusieurs manières alors je sais pas
si vous allez me le demander de donner
alors nous on a relayé celle par SMS
notamment on peut faire un don de 5 € en
envoyant dont 78 ou 92200
produits d'hygiène pour les mamans et
les enfants je vous le dis parce qu'on a
une augmentation énorme de familles avec
maman et enfants en bas âge qui viennent
nous voir on a des espaces bébé parents
et vraiment on a de gros gros besoins
voilà je veux bénévole aussi bénévole
d'un jour pour séjourner ou peut-être
bénévoles toujours sur pour la Croix
Rouge c'est là où nous on va s'adapter
vous voyez effectivement rejoignez-nous
venez qui était une heure et demie ça
nous fera une heure et demie un tronc
qui va se remplir vraiment voilà vous
pouvez venir nous rejoindre vous avez 16
unités locales réparties dans les
Yvelines aller sur le site
www.rouge française vous trouverez
toutes les adresses des unités locales
absolument c'est de plus en plus
difficile aujourd'hui de trouver des
bénévoles vous le disiez alors nous on
avait reçu très dernièrement les
responsables de l'antenne de l'épicerie
sociale des longs
il y a un risque pour l'avenir de cette
structure
d'essayer de venir la Croix-Rouge peut
proposer plein d'actions différentes
alors il y a l'alimentaire c'est vrai
mais vous pouvez venir aussi pour
l'urgence vous pouvez venir aussi pour
en fait on peut trouver son bonheur dans
plein d'actions différentes à la
Croix-Rouge on peut devenir secouriste
on a besoin de secourisme on peut voilà
donc l'alimentaire oui on a besoin de
bénévoles et puis nous on va essayer de
faire évoluer nos horaires de pouvoir on
a plein de choses à faire nous également
pour que les gens viennent et ils vont
finir par revenir enfin non mais on en a
encore heureusement
on traverse une crise du bénévolat vous
le ressentez aussi au niveau de
l'organisation de festival comme blue
sur scène blue sur scène a beaucoup de
chance nous avons un groupe de bénévoles
fidèles depuis très longtemps et ils
sont toujours là ils sont nous avons
pour les deux festivals plus de 70
bénévoles
un dernier mot Martine Delabarre sur
quel appel vous souhaitez passer au
téléspectateurs à l'orée de ses journées
vraiment vous allez trouver des
bénévoles sur tous les croisements des
gros Carrefour dans les marchés dans les
supermarchés
faites-leur le meilleur accueil voilà si
si vous je crois que nous on nous voit
souvent dans les routes on nous voit
souvent en urgence
vraiment c'est le moment de nous dire on
vous soutient en fait soutenez-nous
voilà et donc pour vous soutenir il
faudrait être présent pour ces journées
du 3 en juin et le 11 juin
cette date c'est ces dates ce sont bien
sûr celles des journées nationales de la
Croix-Rouge avec toutes les informations
à retrouver bien sûr sur le site
internet de la Croix-Rouge qui s'affiche
sur l'écran merci Martine Delabarre
présente de la délégation des Yvelines
de la Croix-Rouge